Boom,
we're live shutting a laptop.
I don't need that.
You've got a flip phone.
I had a flip phone.
I don't need a fucking lap.
No,
no electronics today.
I got a flip phone.
What a simple guy.
You know what I mean?
A long time.
What do I need?
I take.
I get texts and make a call.
Do you do like at least give you a full
keyboard for text?
Are you doing so?
That way if you text me,
I'll give you an answer,
but it's going to take a awhile and just
give you a quick gauge.
I can't have a conversation like people
don't.
Some people get ridiculous,
although you up to what do I.
What am I up to?
Exactly what you want to talk like a 12
year old girl.
Call me,
man.
What are we doing?
I mean,
I'm not a teenager.
Call me.
You want me to talk?
That's what I'm saying.
Shit.
Good to see you,
brother.
It's been a long time.
Really locked in on you for a long
fucking time.
Dude.
It's.
It's interesting to see a friend who was
in,
I mean you were always in show business
because you ran the Riviera,
but to go from that to being on the
soprano's I remember hearing about it
and then seeing it and the sopranos was
my favorite show at the time.
I read it to you I think in little Italy
way back when,
when I was living down there,
so it had to be early 2000 like that
99,000.
I just couldn't believe it.
It was just,
it was so weird watching a guy like you
all of a sudden was just a friend.
All of a sudden you're on my favorite
show is,
it's a strange thing to watch someone
who you like who's on a show playing
somebody else.
No,
you know what the thing is,
I can't even say like,
you know,
Joe,
like I couldn't even say,
well you don't lose your dream man.
I always wanted to do it because I never
wanted to,
you know,
I was like screwing around,
and uh,
I think pollock put me in one of his
things and Bruce Baum and you know,
I was running the club,
used to work the club,
right?
The extreme comedy get bummed out.
When I heard they were tearing down the
Riviera.
A lot of people,
a lot of people really got sad.
I wish I could have went back because it
was,
it was at one time.
It was good.
It was really good.
Was it gone now?
Is it go?
They're not going to done.
I think they should talk to Schumer
taught,
shown,
you know,
knocking the thing that I saw dice in
the upstairs room like a year and a half
ago or so.
I went down there and he was doing,
they started doing shows up there,
the Amy Schumer and they did dice and
Gilbert and a bunch of people in that.
They used to be the female impersonators
ship.
Yes.
Yeah.
That guy's still around,
but we just keep on going,
keep pictures of them.
They should be arrested for fraud,
for fucking picture they use in.
The guy's got to be in the seventies and
I know he's 85 years old.
He's at least 100.
He's got a house.
He's got a house like A.
I had a film something at his house once
and it's like a mini liberace.
Like that kind of thing.
You just what you think it is?
Yeah,
that's what it is.
I'm sure you know.
He also would be crazy,
like he had a housekeeper and he would
like to leave things around on purpose,
see if they were clean.
And you know that one of those guys,
he's still gone.
I think he's at the,
I don't know the imperial.
What's one is one of those strange
casino.
He's one of those,
but they still gone and then there's the
guy still playing.
The guy that does Tina Turner is older
than 10 to 10.
Well,
I remember watching that show once that
show I watched once and crazy girl I
watched.
There was comics used to come in and out
of their staff over the years.
I remember years ago they needed a
filling.
I put sinbad and they're real crazy
girls because it was upstairs,
you know,
the show's been around for years and
they all ran simultaneously,
which the three,
you know,
hey,
we had the comedy club,
he had a cottage crazy girls.
So it was all,
you know.
Yeah,
no,
I remember it was,
it was,
uh,
it was the first place I ever worked in
Vegas.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
I did that extreme comedy xxx right.
He came in for the weekend,
which was great.
Puts you in the suite,
do the thing.
I took a photo of my name on the marquee
because I was like,
look at that.
It's my name's.
I had one of those cameras that you're
buying.
It looked a lot at a lot of stuff.
I started at 1986.
Whoa.
You know,
way back when it was still like,
you know,
one of the Ta,
still a good hotel.
I mean,
my brother,
that's what you're trying to say,
that that Kinda was gone.
But then you had rick who was kinda
different,
kinda mobster,
you know,
he was in Israel,
he started the junk bonds.
He who is he?
He was married to Peter the door.
He owned it when I was there.
So they just found a different way to
skim the money,
you know,
through construction or whatever.
They weren't bag man.
It was just a different,
different deals.
Like the air conditioners he bought for
the new building,
they were from Israel,
like they didn't have parts in the
United States.
So like all the,
you know what I'm saying?
It was there.
They found different ways,
but he was good to me.
You know,
he was good to me.
Rick,
he owned the hotel when I first got
there in [inaudible] 86 and Sinatra was,
you know,
played there in [inaudible] 88,
89,
90 Sinatra was there.
You still had a license and playing
there.
You had a Milton Berle,
Sid Caesar,
they,
I mean it was still playing,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was a lot of stuff came to us.
He got to see all those people.
They saw Sinatra night after night after
night and I just,
after I was done work,
I'll go sit in the back of the room,
you know,
sometimes my wife would come,
you know.
Wow.
And it was,
you know,
it was like no big deal after a while,
it's crazy.
I got a tape of him.
I got a tape of him on New Year's Eve,
I think it's New Year's Eve.
[inaudible] 89 or 90 to guys to the
soundman took it.
It was close circuit.
Remember the closed circuit in the room
and they're just in the room and they
put a vhs,
vhs and Beta Max or whatever the hell it
was.
And uh,
he's drunk.
His toupees kind of crooked.
And Joey Remember Joey Villa?
He was a comic,
like a real,
you know,
real hacky,
thethey guy.
He was in splash that show.
Okay.
So you had joey villa opened the door
and then driessen open for a Tom Dreesen
open for a Sinatra and he did a show
upstairs and downstairs he was drunk on
his ass and archer.
And I have a tape of it somewhere.
I still have it somewhere and he played.
He says,
I don't care.
I play upstairs.
I played downstairs.
If they pay me,
I sing in a phone booth.
He didn't care at that point.
Wow.
How old was he back then?
I don't know.
He just turned 100.
It was like 1990.
So that was probably the beginning of
the end.
Right before he started losing a little.
He had a teleprompter onstage,
you know,
he was reading though,
he wasn't completely out of it,
but you know,
I think he died in [inaudible] 99 if I'm
not mistaken.
So,
uh,
he would forget his lyrics.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Because it was so hammered.
There was just no,
no,
I just think he was getting older and I
think to be honest,
my opinion that kept them out there too
long,
you know,
I think whoever the powers may be,
I don't know who that was.
I think he stayed a little too long
there,
you know,
but I hate to see him.
I saw him in [inaudible] 82 when I first
got to town and 80,
I saw him 1981,
82 83 in those days and she's just.
I mean,
that was something I saw Sammy Davis,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah,
I saw all those,
you know,
Johnny Martin told those guys that were
there.
I saw a lot of stuff that people were
gone,
you know?
Yeah.
You like caught the bridge for the last
of the exact.
Absolutely.
When I moved in it was 350,000
people when I was friendly with the
casino,
the Joe Pesci character,
Tony Spilotro,
his character.
I was friendly with that guy.
I was a bouncer.
He would come in the club all the time,
go the club.
He always give me a 20,
you know,
Kevin,
he was giving me $20 for years.
If I was a bartender to send up a 20.
He was always a good guy to me.
Now I don't know what he did,
but he didn't do.
He was good to me.
I didn't know the,
the uh,
I didn't know that Deniro character him.
I never knew he was around,
but I didn't know him,
but the Pegi character,
uh,
Tony splotch show and he had a guy,
fat Herbie and I was there.
His son got married.
I was the bouncer at the wedding to make
sure FBI didn't get into the,
into the wedding sweater guy.
They had a volunteer at the wedding,
bounces Tuxedo.
I was about to do it and make sure
nobody that's not on that list doesn't
come in,
but they're worried about the FBI at the
wedding.
They were worried because at the time
there was,
you know,
it was a small town.
It was easy.
I mean,
you know,
they were doing whatever they were
doing.
I mean,
I don't know,
you know,
I mean,
I was never privy to any of that,
but they were around.
How close was he to the character that
she played?
You know,
I didn't see the nastiness he'd,
she caught the,
the voice and the accent.
He has that,
the Chicago.
And uh,
I only saw him being like a gentleman,
you know,
to be honest.
He had kids and I mean,
that's all I saw.
He was,
you know,
you have some drinks.
He's in the club,
but I didn't do anything crazy.
Well,
they always exaggerate things for shows
and movies.
I of course.
I mean,
I would assume,
I don't know where they got it from,
but yeah,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
he was around,
he was kind of the Bosch in town,
you know,
in the movie he got beat to death with a
baseball bat.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
And I think that did happen I think in a
cornfield.
Him and his brother back in Chicago.
Yeah.
But you know,
there was a small town.
Everybody knew everybody was two clubs,
no clubs,
no clubs at all in the casinos.
That was,
there was no nightclubs really know.
My coach that started in the nineties I
think at the real was no night clubs
that had two clubs in town.
Paul anchor on one and then there was
another one,
like I would go to work at one in the
morning to nine in the morning and I
would leave and the dance floor was
packed at 9:00,
9:00
AM.
Wow.
And then people would go out from there
was just a completely different thing,
you know,
and all the entertainers would come out,
like,
I mean I saw Oj and cosby was out all
the time and rich little and it was ever
was bob hope,
Bob Hope came into to club.
He left the uh,
the,
the bathroom attended thirty cents,
30,
30.
Got a quarter.
And,
and Nicole,
that's hilarious that you remember that
though.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
there's certain things.
I remember the name Copperfield gave me
$2.
He said,
hey,
if there's any girls,
bring them over to that sweaty,
sweaty my hand to God,
my $2.
And uh,
he,
he wasn't,
you know,
he was headlining but not that famous
yet.
But give me like two bucks,
three bucks.
He said,
hey,
you know,
any girls,
girls and bring them this way.
And it me time.
I had guys giving me hundreds.
You know,
it's all dope deal is,
you know,
back then it was all crazy.
Kenneth did cost me have the reputation
back then.
He didn't have a reputation of doing
anything to the girls,
but always chasing girls.
Always,
always,
always.
But he didn't have the reputation of
drugs.
No,
no,
I didn't know anything about any of
that.
I also knew that,
uh,
there was a time he didn't tip,
you know,
there's a lot of these guys don't want
to,
you know,
Scotty pippin's famous,
no tip in pippin.
That was his nickname and I heard that,
you know,
holding Michael Jordan,
and the worst of all is tiger woods.
He's the absolute worst Tipa.
And you could ask anyone that's.
There was a girl that I knew,
she managed the restaurant and she was
friendly with them and they would go
out,
you know,
not just turned him,
like a group or whatever.
She said I couldn't afford to go out
with him anymore because I was leaving
tips because he would,
you know,
obviously it's costing me three,
$400 just from cleaning up his mess.
Luck.
Oh my God.
Why is that guy do that?
I don't understand how a guy,
because I don't want us to not rich
because I think sometimes joe,
I think guys,
it's a privilege for you to have me in
your place.
I think it gets to that point.
That's what it should have been raising.
You know,
I listen,
when I started making more money,
I started taking better care of people.
I mean,
I was of course in Tampa,
but come on man,
you know,
you're,
you're lucky enough to,
you know,
you've done well.
Knock on wood,
I've done well.
I mean with the help,
pay it forward a little bit.
You don't feel it.
That's the thing.
Of course not.
If I lose 100 bucks at a dinner that
night,
they go home and they,
Joe Rogan,
you know,
he gave me.
He took good care of me.
You may disguise night.
This guy's probably got two kids or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
You know what I like to do,
like to do it and get the fuck out of
there before they realize it.
I call it like leave it a love bomb.
I agree with bomb.
Get out of the room.
I agree with you,
you know,
you gotTa,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
some people I think,
and it happens a lot,
you hear it all the time.
A lot of athletes especially,
you know.
Yeah.
Well is the ego that's involved with
being an athlete sometimes.
Like I'm the man,
I can't be stopped.
Um,
you know,
fuck everybody else agree with that.
It sort of breeds it.
But there's female,
like if you go like dealers in vegas,
especially because everybody comes
through there.
There's like,
I think it was athletic when he was
dating j Lo might party was a crap deal.
And uh,
he left them five grand and she picked
up 45,
you know,
in chips and she picked it all up a 500
and left 500.
He left the 5,000
tip.
She picked it up and like,
absolutely what she stole.
She's a fucking thief.
Knew she did it,
but she wasn't leaving that much.
Fuck.
But you know,
you see it all the time.
All the time.
Tell you though,
I remember guys that took me years ago
like way back when Tony Danza who I'm
friends with,
I gave him $20 less like in 1981.
He gave me a 20.
That's like a big part of like the whole
culture of Vegas is typically always has
been.
And the thing is if you want to get
treated right,
you need to tip.
Yeah,
that's it.
It doesn't,
it doesn't even take that much.
Guys don't understand that.
Waiting online for three hours at the
buffet.
I mean why don't you just give the guy
$20,
$10 and you get in the line.
Right now I understand is a guy like
tiger woods,
like he's not going to feel $100 to 100
bucks that that won't,
but that's a character flaw,
man.
That's a character flaw that you just
don't want to share.
I mean that's.
You don't.
They don't deserve it.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's just so crazy to me.
I just don't understand it.
Plus if I want to get treated good,
it doesn't matter who you are.
You could be a plumber from encino and
throw a few bucks around and you're
going to get treated like a king for,
you know,
what's it take?
Well,
that's what that whole town is about.
At least it wasn't when it was built on.
They kind of took that away because a
lot of people,
and it started with Steve when a lot of
people.
He was a big one.
He did.
He thought they would make it too much
money.
The deal is the waitresses,
the captains in the show room.
I got a 90 year old friend,
was the captain in the showroom during
Elvis at the Hilton.
He was making $800 a night cash in the
seventies.
A lot of money.
That's probably like 8,000
in Vegas at the time.
Your cost,
it still doesn't cost a much to live in
Vegas.
But then of course nothing.
So these guys were buying land and they
were invested in and,
and,
and going out at night and it was
trickling down really well when stopped
all that.
So he's the first guy to do the numbered
seeding.
What did he.
I don't understand what he did the
summer.
He got rid of all those captains,
maitre d's,
waitresses,
you know,
he days.
Well,
he got there.
They no longer.
When you have a show in Vegas,
do you have a number ticket to get in?
Right.
Those people know where they're going.
It didn't used to be that way.
You used to buy,
you know you're going to go in and then
you tip the Maitre d,
$20,
$30,
$40,
and you get a good seat.
That's what Vegas was built on for years
and years and years.
He stopped all that same thing with a
dealer.
He didn't want them to make as much,
so they put it on the check.
Now they all pull no matter whether you
work hard enough,
so when you go into a game,
when you go to a blackjack game and you
got to deal with that's a prick and you
saw this bitch,
I'm not going to give her anything.
You don't tip.
And then there's a nice guy and you say,
you know what?
He's a lot of fun.
I'm going to give him $100.
Well,
at the end of the night,
that all goes into a big pool.
Twenty four hours a day.
Every deal splits them up.
That sounds ridiculous,
is ridiculous.
So some guys are slack is and they go,
hey man,
I ain't got out of this is going to go
be a mechanic,
you know,
just going to be a robot and do what I
do.
And no personality and flair.
It's exactly what.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
So that whole Steve Wynn decided to do
that because I think he thought people
tip and big make it too much money.
Money that could have been instead of
tip and he'll make the money,
you know,
instead of me giving the Maitre d $100
for a good seat,
I'm just going to charge them $100 for c
and I'm going to get the money.
That's how it is.
Now,
you know,
expensive tickets are in Vegas.
Oh,
that's awful.
Got Comedy Club in Vegas.
Costs like $60 a song.
I really like the Brad Garrett.
Yeah,
I think it's like $60.
That's a nice little club.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's done well.
It's him and uh,
the left factory now are the big ones to
Riv went away.
The improv I just read is going away in
May.
They've been there a long time.
The,
uh,
the laugh factory dice is doing a
residency.
Oh,
he,
yeah,
he's doing like a temporary residency.
It's kind of like blocked off some dates
do well.
Who was doing?
Yeah,
he'll do well.
Well,
he's got that new showtime show now.
He had called me.
He wanted me to read for a role there,
which I really love because he's,
I think he's funny and he's good.
He would have been great on that.
He's a good actor.
He's always thought he was a really good
active way back from crime story.
I do remember that.
Do you.
Did you ever see that Woody Allen movie?
Blue Jasmine?
Absolutely was excellent in that movie.
It was really good actor.
He's good guy.
He's done the other stuff too,
you know,
before that,
I mean,
it just finally,
after all the other stuff,
they,
they recognized that and I think he
shows funny.
It is funny.
Well,
at that.
And so it was Natasha,
his wife on the show.
She's fucking Kevin Crogan the other
night in New York.
Kevin the plays a side kicked in.
Yeah.
I saw him the other night.
I ran into him.
What?
Dice took a lot of shit for a long time
and now it's finally coming around.
It's cool to like dice again.
You know why it went so bad in the first
place I don't solve it was MTV and
political correctness and it was just a
different time back then.
Like they were trying to get away with
that.
They're trying to move away from that
kind of humor that he was doing.
Yeah.
But the thing is,
which you know,
like you're a comedian who's to say,
who could say what onstage and what's
funny.
Exactly.
Funny.
And we could go round and round and I
can't make a joke about this.
Well,
that's what the whole thing's about.
Do you know a guy like Buddy Hackett and
those old comics that you should do
Polish jokes and a Chinese jokes and
Japanese jokes?
They couldn't even work now.
No.
That's out of the picture.
You know,
you know those guys,
you should do the accents and all that
nonsense and uh,
you know,
you can still make fun of white people
if you're a black guy can make fun of
white people.
That's,
that's totally acceptable and you can't,
you can't make fun of black people.
No,
no,
no.
Even light skinned.
Black people have a hard time making fun
of black people.
GotTa very careful.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I don't get all that,
but that swung so far joe sometimes that
I'm not a political guy.
I think that it's so broken in the
country.
It can't be fixed.
Well,
you know,
what it is I think is more people have
opinions now.
More people can express their opinions
now.
It's just a different world.
Whereas there's so much coming at you
from so many different angles and then
people realize they can express their
opinions.
So many people realize that if they say
something on facebook,
it'll get a bunch of likes.
Or if they say something on twitter,
but it's easy to do that stuff
anonymous.
A lot of people don't want to.
They don't want to though,
a lot of people don't want to do it
anonymous,
but they all do it or not.
There's that two people that could just,
you know,
motherfucker you from now until forever
and you don't even know who the guy is.
That's true.
But when they see it,
they still know they did it.
So that's why they're doing it.
They're doing it to get attention.
Even if the attention doesn't directly
come to them in,
you know,
as Steve [inaudible] name,
it doesn't come at their name.
It's still,
they know that fuck face 69,
the twitter profile.
They know,
they make that and so when they're
saying something nasty about you,
they know that they're the one that
wrote it and he responded and tell their
friends.
You know,
it's just people.
People just,
it's,
it's a new thing.
It's a new thing to be able to reach out
to people.
It's a new thing to be able to protest,
to comment
on people and to be able to organize
things like very easily.
Like if a comedian,
like,
um,
any comedian,
you know,
if they say something that someone
thinks is crosses along,
they can organize a boycott.
They want to get them kicked off a
television show.
I mean,
it happens over and over and over.
They're keeping these guys from working.
Yeah,
keeping these guys from working for
what?
Well,
because they're just constantly of
chilling the,
the,
the announcer for espn,
they just get fired because he doesn't
believe the transgender bathroom thing.
Was that what he got fired?
They got fired for that and he kept
talking about,
well,
you know what?
He had a picture that he put on twitter
that showed a guy in a dress with his
tits hanging out that said,
under this new law,
this guy could share a bathroom with
your daughter.
Yeah.
So your to get fired for that.
Well,
here's the deal,
here's the deal.
Um,
that is possible.
And in,
in someone not admitting that that
doesn't help anybody.
I mean,
it just doesn't,
it doesn't help.
It doesn't help.
But goddamn thing that,
that is possible.
Like you could get a fucking nut bag who
wears a dress and what's a whip his cock
out in front of women and says there's a
woman that that is a real thing.
Like I'm not saying that it should.
Yeah,
I mean I'm not saying that that's the
majority,
but we got to define what's a woman and
what's not a woman.
If you're going to allow transgender
people to transition and become a the
other gender,
whether it's woman to Male,
male to female,
you gotta,
we gotta make some sort of a standard
where we know that that's exactly what's
going on in this.
Not just someone who's a crazy fuck
wants to wear a dress,
but how do you do that?
That's a great question.
How do you do that?
Well,
that's why the idea of making people go
to a bathroom that is their gender,
what they're born with,
like their sex,
what's their chromosomes?
It's not preposterous and everybody's
making it seem like it's bigoted to
force people to use a bathroom that
matches their chromosomes and that's
kind of crazy.
You know?
And it's not saying that you should
discriminate against transgender people
or people who feel like they were born
in the wrong sex.
No,
not at all.
Maybe we need to have three fucking
bathrooms.
Yeah.
Maybe we need to.
Probably the easy one.
Maybe it should be male,
female and go for it until you do
remember in crazy girls.
I don't know if you remember the girl
that was the MC.
Excuse me.
John was steel.
She was a got a buzzard chopped or
whatever that is.
I do remember because we met her.
She was.
And I met her and she showed it to joey
and Joey said it looked like a bat with
its mouth open.
That's hilarious.
But she was,
you know,
I was friendly with.
She was great.
She had the mind of a guy,
you know what I mean?
She,
we met with a lot of different guys and
she was very funny.
She's very funny.
Very funny.
She looked a lot like a woman.
Absolutely.
If I don't know,
if I would've known if I would have
known,
you know what I'm saying?
And this is 19.
What was it,
90 or something or even before that?
Yeah,
so,
but the bottom,
the bottom line about that kind of stuff
is you're not allowed to even talk about
it.
If you talk about it,
you're a bigot.
Like we have to leave open the
possibility.
There's some crazy fucks out there.
There's some guys that would just decide
that all they have to do to hang on a
woman's room is dressed like a woman.
That doesn't mean that there's aren't.
They aren't real transgenders.
Like what was the name?
Jonah?
Jonah.
Jonah doesn't like her go into a woman's
bathroom.
Absolutely.
One hundred percent.
But what about Joey Diaz with Joey Diaz
put on a fucking dress.
I'm not joking around.
I mean that.
That is entirely possible.
There is a guy that said that he was,
that he,
he identifies as being a six year old
girl.
He's a 52 year old man.
He dresses up like a girl.
He's got.
He's got parents,
he's got a daughter,
he's got a family and he identifies as
being a six year old girl.
I mean,
what,
when do you stop that?
Like is everybody just allowed to play,
make believe?
Because understand I think I'm a wolf.
I identify with being a wolf.
I'm going to wear a wolf skin everywhere
and I'm going to lift my leg to piss on
fire hydrants.
Just like a dog.
That's what I'm saying.
I think it's so far everything's so
broken,
Joel.
Crazy.
It's can't be fixed.
I think Carlin,
George Carlin,
he knew this guy meet that 52 year old
father who identifies as a six year old
girl.
This is not a joke.
I mean people are out of their fucking
minds and the thing is so I can't deny I
was married.
I can't deny I have children.
He says,
well then you're a fucking father.
What happened to loving yourself?
Whatever happened to that,
but it wasn't that something that was
preached for the longest time.
Love yourself for who you are.
Don't try to change yourself.
Don't look to get your fucking chin
shaved down,
eyebrows raised,
and that knows the plastic surgery world
now,
right?
True.
The whole place we showed you will at
some point,
a lot of these girls are going to look
exactly the same because you see some of
them now,
just regular girls.
Don't you see this and this?
There's a lot of old ladies in my
neighborhood that are fucking monster
faces.
What I call them,
they get that rubber face.
Absolutely.
You know when they shoot the fillers in
there and the whole face swells up and
it looks like a monster.
They look alike,
immobile,
Kabuki mask.
The thing is this,
you know,
how do you looking?
You look yourself in the mirror and go,
you know,
it's pretty good.
Hey,
this shit.
How many actresses have ruined them?
Ruined their careers because they
changed their face.
Oh,
quite a few.
Quite a few.
Well,
I think the problem is they think that
they look different than they look.
You know,
and they think so it's going to work.
They think it's gonna work and then
everybody else sees them and then they
see what everybody else sees me.
Oh my God,
what have I done here?
It's dysmorphia.
It's the same thing.
Anorexic,
Savick,
same thing.
Bodybuilders have where they think that
they look normal and they're fucking
gigantic and they think they're too
small.
You know it's body dysmorphia.
That's what it is.
People are crazy.
I don't have to worry about.
You've always been fine.
It is what it is.
It ain't going to do this.
Here we go.
With that attitude of it is what it is,
is really what we should all have.
I mean that's,
that's how it looked when I was younger.
I was in better shape.
You know,
I played ball.
I was an athlete in college.
I gained weight.
No,
I got laid as much as I wanted when I
was young and in Vegas and all that,
and then I gained weight.
I try to watch,
but what it is,
I'm not going to change the way I look
like I got to be a leading man.
It is what it is.
It's a girl says you want makeup during
the show.
It doesn't really matter.
It's just the idea of you being better
looking because you're less shiny.
He didn't know.
He has always been a bizarre.
It is what it is.
I'm not an anchorman.
They have a lot of makeup.
You know,
you ever do a talk show,
you looking at the guy,
he,
I can't believe how much wake up this
guy take it on.
There's a lot of those shows where they,
they literally change what they look
like.
Like if you look at them in real life.
Look,
yeah,
they tell you this,
you know.
Well HDTV fucked a lot of that people.
I mean,
even myself,
I can.
I,
you don't like to watch myself.
I'm doing blue bloods now.
I'm looking at myself and go my heads.
I got to,
I just got a big screen.
Sixty five inch and my head's fucking
giant.
It's filling up the whole 65 inches.
What?
This blue bloods.
Blue bloods is a CBS.
It's a one hour drama.
Tom Selleck,
Tommy.
Well,
Donny Walberg.
Oh,
you're working with Tom Selleck.
I started in October to really get you
into the aisle next to this true shows.
Left Friday night.
I got a big one.
I joined in October two.
It's a really good show and they play a
DA investigator,
so I'm on the other side of the law,
you know.
Nice.
And uh,
it's really good.
The writing's really good.
You'll be surprised.
It's a network show and it's really,
really good.
It's been a,
they just got picked up for seven
season.
What's Tom Selleck like?
You know,
I met him twice.
I didn't work with them because I'm
working with,
with bridget Moynahan mostly.
Very nice.
She's great.
Great.
She,
uh,
he came into the trailer,
he said you're doing great work.
Thanks for being here.
I'm shook my hand a few times and I
haven't seen them.
So you don't know because it's Kinda the
way it's worked so far is I've worked
with Donny Walberg once who was a great
guy and then I worked with her all the
time.
I haven't worked with anyone else,
you know,
the other guest stars,
but it's been,
it's been good,
you know,
it tragic shooting in New York all over
the city.
So it's like the city's like another
character,
you know,
it's shooting every borrow.
So you live in New York now?
I live in New York.
I lived downtown.
Yeah,
I've been there.
I sold my house in Vegas a few years
ago,
but I've been in there with my family
since about 2002 d like it.
Yeah,
I like it.
Not too crazy.
A little crazy.
It's got the goes a piece of garbage,
you know,
he's a bad guy.
Just a guy.
Yeah.
And he,
he put the city in the toilet and
there's a lot of homeless,
but got rid of the big gulp.
Yeah.
But Joe,
that's to the other extreme.
Now this guy's a jackass.
I mean this guy wanted to separate the
city between the cops and,
and he did it.
He's a bad guy.
This guy,
you know,
just.
And now he's under investigation for one
campaign,
fraud and all kinds of shit.
The FBI came in.
So I like it.
It's crazy,
but it's great.
There's always something going on.
It's vibrant.
I like southern California,
you know,
I'm looking,
rent the place to here too also.
But I like it.
I like Neil,
you know,
I got my friends at and from there,
it's,
it's not,
it's insane this,
you know,
you've been spent time there.
It's crazy people.
Yeah.
I looked at a place there for awhile
while a while ago,
like maybe two,
three years ago.
I thought about it.
I said a while here across.
I said,
Mike,
if my kids were born there,
you know,
both of my daughters grew up there.
I mean my kids were born in Vegas,
but they grew up there in New York and
my wife was born in Vegas and she loves
that.
It's.
I mean,
if you've got some money,
it's not the worst place in the world to
live.
You got to have money because it's
ridiculously expensive.
What's changed too?
It's become like bankers,
like a buddy of mine was talking about
that.
It used to be a Judah Judah freelander.
Yeah.
Judy was saying that it used to be like
a lot of artists,
but now this is the problem.
It's in 20 years when like the rent
control shit expires and people's,
you're going to have to be wealthy to
live in Manhattan.
You're going to have to be literally
wealthy,
so all the kids that want to become
comics and artists and actors and
dancers and they get out of high school
and college can't afford to live there
unless they have rich parents or parents
that could help them.
They can't afford.
So they living in bedstuy and other
neighborhoods,
which is good for the neighborhoods
because they're changing.
But they live in four and five to a two
bedroom apartment.
Yeah.
A buddy of mine got a place in Bedstein
because he was working for a production
company in New York.
You can't do it any other way.
He said they started a cleaning.
The house happened.
They found with all the paint and the
house was lead and he had a kid.
He's like,
we gotta get the fuck out of here,
like this paint.
So you know,
you got to go further out to Queens,
further out to Brooklyn,
you know,
where it's still affordable,
but you know,
to an hour into the city clock that,
you know by train.
But if you could look,
I live in that and I bought a condo
years ago or three bedroom,
you know,
got a nice place.
If you could afford it,
it's great.
But at some point,
if it doesn't stop places are out of
business stores,
guys who had a business for 30 years,
did the,
you know,
the lease is up.
He's gone.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just everyone's greedy pig.
Well it's just the whole landscape of
the city is changing and when I talk to
comics they say the audiences are
changing too.
It's like you're dealing with like Wall
Street people are like,
you're.
Yeah.
I haven't been to a comedy club and
quite awhile I don't.
I,
you know,
I don't know that uh,
you know what I mean?
You got to caroline's and Gotham or
caroline's is really a tourist trap and
you got Gotham Club.
I mean,
it still is great acts,
but it's not like they don't do like,
it's not like a big local scene,
you know,
you've got the stand is like a big local
scene.
The seller got,
you've got a lot of clubs were comics
workout at,
but caroline's is more of like a who,
you know,
like someone's out of town,
they go in there and they do a weekend
and you know,
I haven't,
you know,
I'm not privy to that,
but it,
it's uh,
you,
you can't,
those kids that want to,
you want to be an actor,
you better have a rich mother and father
lived there.
I lived in new Rochelle because I
couldn't afford to park my car and I
needed a car for a road gigs.
Yeah.
But it was not.
I mean it was ridiculous back then.
It was expensive,
but I think I moved there in 91 or 92,
somewhere around there.
And I lived there.
I lived in new Rochelle.
I kept an apartment there for three
years.
So 90 to about 90,
somewhere around 95 ish.
I believe that apartments that were
double.
No,
no,
it was a small little shitty place in a
weird neighborhood.
It's just gotten way out of control and
these land lodge.
And I tell you that the blasio's is
really split the city.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm not just saying I'm not,
I don't get into politics.
I don't know that.
I think that was his intention.
You know,
he's big friends without shopped and
shopped and sometimes I wonder if this
guy's running the city.
Well,
what do you think a guy like that does?
Why?
Why do they do that?
They do it.
Is it a political calculation that like
they think like this is the way to get
the black vote.
Oh,
the white people are just going to go
along with.
Absolutely.
And let me tell you another thing.
A guy like our shop and he makes his
money by shaking people down.
Yeah.
I mean I have a friend of mine who's a
builder there who I can tell you flat
out over the years,
he's given them envelopes because you
know,
what they do is they come,
they'll say,
you know,
we got the coalition here.
We're going to shut down,
going to shut your job down unless you
hire 10 guys and I'm not even saying
black,
white,
Spanish.
I'm not even saying what it is.
This is what these guys do and either
you hire the 10 guys or they get an
envelope and this was,
goes on.
This is what goes on.
Well,
Jesse Jackson's been cancer that
forever.
Jesse Jackson and this was a fact,
uh,
the uh,
in Vegas in the eighties to frontier was
on strike for like six or seven years
from the food and beverage.
You know,
the way it is in the protests.
They paid him 25 grand to march with
them down the strip.
They closed the,
stripped out 25 grand.
Why people are coming up to Jesse
Jackson going,
hey,
you know,
that's great.
Thank you man.
Thank you.
And in the meantime he got paid.
Yeah,
well that was his hustle.
The Rainbow Coalition.
They come in and do the whole thing is
diversity lessons to everybody that
worked there,
you know,
they would,
they would have these clinics.
So they teach people how to be more
diverse.
This is what's out shopping and done.
He owes taxes.
He owes.
That couldn't be a bigger hustler.
I think he could kill somebody in broad
daylight.
He'll get away.
So he walked in front of the comedy
store.
One night he was walking down the street
walking right in front of the comedy
store and me and a bunch of other
comedians just started heckling him as
he was walking by how shopped and get
that money.
Go get that money out.
He's a hustler.
We ain't mad at you.
Go get that money.
I mean,
he's been in the White House.
How many times the guys in the White
House.
Not only that,
if you go back to his history,
there's no white guy would have ever
gotten away with that.
And he would.
He did.
Was he got into the public's eye because
of false rape accusations?
Totally made up stories.
He's never admitted to that.
No.
Bullying was proven.
I mean it was absolutely proven lowly
and they,
you've ruined the guys life up there and
then that guy shoot and yeah.
Well,
so keeps telling.
He's in the White House.
He's in the window.
So we go on and on and on.
I mean that happen.
How does someone not step away from
that?
That's why I'm telling you.
It's so broken.
Can't be fixed.
You've got to drop out of sight.
Joe,
what are we going to do?
I don't know.
Alaska is.
I don't think that's.
I think an accurate China like it up
there.
Hawaii.
Dangerous Sharks.
The waves.
The fucking you'd go anymore.
I don't know.
I'll be in the middle of the ocean.
It's just too dangerous.
Although it has been there for thousands
of years and I won't be here for
thousands of years.
So it's tempting in that regard.
We're doomed.
Doomed.
I Dunno.
I like where people are so I'm thinking
Montana,
that might be a good spot.
They don't give a fuck.
Not many people.
They don't give up on patrol lives of
Montana.
Absolutely.
Harris.
Pete and retro.
That's right.
Harris.
Pete used to take care of his place,
right?
They live up there.
No,
they don't live together.
No.
Harris Pete.
Yeah.
It's like how could we all get along
with Harris is a.
I was up there.
It's a strange place.
It's not a bad place,
just not for me.
I'm not one of them.
Yeah.
I'm not an outdoor guy.
Can't.
You can't do anything.
I can't change a light bulb.
Light Bulb.
I got to call the guy downstairs.
Could you change the bulb?
I got to live in a doorman building the
doorman building.
That's your environment,
your natural.
Yet I got a tip.
Somebody your natural habitats with
doorman building.
That's fucking hilarious.
Tip somebody to do it.
So,
uh,
you're making spaghetti sauce now.
I ate it last night and I had it today.
I just want to tell you.
It's very good.
So no bullshit.
How the fuck did you get involved in
making spaghetti sauce?
I had my buddy,
my buddy Joe,
right?
Uh,
my mother had passed away a few years
ago.
He said,
let's do something for your mother.
Come on,
let's duchamp.
You know,
he's an entrepreneurial kind of guy,
you know,
and uh,
so we got the recipe and I,
my wife runs marathons,
she's healthy,
she eats organic,
blah,
blah.
We made it organic.
It took a while.
We had to throw out a lot of sauce and
give it to shelters and stuff like that
because it was too loose and it was,
you know,
not bad.
It just wasn't prevalent wanted.
We got it.
It's organic.
Gluten free,
non GMO,
uncle Steve's.
She'd go to uncle Steve's and wide that
come.
We sell it.
It's just we just got here an
Albertsons,
Vons pavilion.
We're in a whole foods fairway,
uh,
all over the country.
Women,
3000 stores.
There it is right here.
Uncle Steve say,
hey dude,
if you didn't know it came out of a job
and I'm not like,
I don't need jobs.
So it's,
you know,
that's that whole Italian thing and I
never did just because I never did.
My wife would cook,
you know,
and when I was a kid,
my mother,
my grandmother and the sauces that good.
My wife hasn't made sauce in a long
time.
Yeah,
I ate it last night.
Like I said,
I ate it this morning.
I ate some this morning.
I'll send you more.
We've got three kinds of cases.
You sent me six tomato,
tomato base,
or did you try to our big Yada?
Ya Know,
I've only tried the marijuana.
The I will be out as very spicy.
Very like it.
It's the biggest seller,
but it's hot.
Keep it away from the kids.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
It's that.
It's spicy.
It's good.
Smart people.
Like my kids,
they're,
my kids are 20 slash 24.
They like you,
they can handle it.
But uh,
not for me to offer me.
You don't like spicy?
Not Spicy Guy.
No.
So I mean,
fuck,
that's amazing,
you know,
that way we don't have to go sit in A.
I don't have to sit in the waiting room
in addition for bullshit.
Yeah.
I mean that's always a good idea to have
alternate sources.
I think,
you know,
uh,
you don't remember this.
We auditioned for something.
It was a movie,
uh,
not the same role,
but it was a movie guy,
Dave Sheridan,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And we were there and I said to you,
who's that fucking guy?
And you and I don't know what the fuck
he was the star of the movie and he
heard us.
I've talked about it.
I got that movie.
I did that.
I talked about that story because not
not you auditioning,
but that whole movie story.
Because that kid was talented.
Yeah,
he was funny as shit.
He was doing okay.
I don't know what that movie was.
Dog Shit.
And one of the reasons why I was dog
shit because all of these executives,
because he was funny and they made him
the star of the movie,
but he was a nobody as far as like
people didn't know who he was.
They all were telling them what to do.
Like I watched a guy with a fucking
rolex on and expensive move in
suspenders,
a frank mccluskey cio.
That's it.
That's that.
Because I did a movie with a producer.
I did his movie before that did the
movie where he was trying to put a hit
on the dogs.
He spotted me.
Paul Sevino.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And then I met you.
You just happen to be.
Then I was there and he was across the
way from us saying,
who's this fucking Dave?
Sharon,
and I say,
so he was the star and I didn't know who
he was.
I didn't get it.
I worked for an attorney.
I think I bought him return well when I
was on the set,
like the kid was really funny.
He's really talented.
He's a very funny,
like real slapsticky big like Jim Carrey
style comic actor and this guy with the
Rolex and the cufflinks and the tailored
suit and suspenders.
Super Rich Guy.
Right?
He's given them line readings.
I mean he's telling this kid like
literally when you come in,
when you come in,
I want you to go,
what is he like?
He's,
he's acting it out and he's like telling
them how to do it and then he sits there
in front of the camera and make sure the
guy does it exactly the way he wants her
to do it.
And you see Dave,
Sharon and gone,
what the fuck is this shit?
I got to do this because the kid was
naturally funny.
And when you got someone who's funny,
one of the last thing you want to do is
tell them how to be funny.
Just leave them the fuck alone.
Make them feel comfortable.
Make them feel comfortable telling them
about somebody would come and cents.
Well they just have so much money.
They have so much money and they have so
much influence and they want to,
they want to make that monkey dance.
I haven't seen.
I don't know if he's working.
I don't know.
I haven't,
But it's just so I have a window.
Was a nice guy though.
I've worked with them.
I had a great time.
He was real nice.
You know?
Uh,
it's just like comics is a goal.
A guy manages of the club.
Used to tell them what to try to do
their act.
What the fuck.
I never told the guy ever.
He never told the guy,
you know,
there's certain things I got the Riv you
couldn't do like this.
Don't knock the hotel.
Right.
You know,
don't,
don't knock tell,
don't say the whole,
it's a shit hole in this shenanigans.
Like I hired a guy,
he,
he went on the radio,
he was saying what a shit hole up a pie
and I,
you know,
my boss called me and he said,
this guy who's just fucking guy in
radio,
and I went,
he said he's gone,
don't bring them back.
So I called the guy said,
why didn't you do that?
I gave you a job now,
why the fuck did you do that?
I think they're being cute and I don't
get it.
So you can't,
you can't come back,
you know.
But I never would tell someone,
hey joe,
that joke you did,
you know,
uh,
that's not funny.
Don't do that joke,
you know,
to that guy used to give me,
they were working as a busboy three
weeks ago.
Now they're running a comedy club and
they're telling you what to do.
Well Pat always amazed that though.
They like telling people what to do.
They always have,
I understand that.
But you know,
you because you got the job at the club
or whatever.
Now suddenly you're in show business
again.
You're speaking like logic.
Come in,
show business.
I mean,
you know how suddenly,
you know
you can't make sense.
There's no sense in this town.
It's not a sense town.
This is not a sense business.
This is a business of navigating egos
and trying to find your own voice.
Nice.
When you're getting your own ego,
it's nice when you don't have to,
uh,
you know,
when you don't have to,
you're not struggling and you know,
and it's okay and you can tell a guy to
fuck off and I'm not going to do that.
And you know what?
Fuck you man,
I'm not coming.
I'm not working for that money in that
thing.
And exactly don't get no fuck.
Fortunately,
not everybody.
I don't have fuck you money.
I have fuck money,
but you know the fuck you.
Money is nice.
You know where you don't have to,
but it's hard.
It's hard to get to that point,
man.
It's very hard to get fucking money and
most people want to get fuck you money.
They're always terrified.
They're going to lose the fuck you
money.
So never say fuck you.
Fuck you.
Money is wasted.
And the people that are afraid to say,
fuck you.
Well said.
Very well said.
It's just so funny.
No one knew for so long and then seeing
you doing so well now as an actor.
And I mean it's,
it's a beautiful thing.
It's also beautiful for me because I
know that you're not,
you're not a classically trained actor.
And I've always told people it's not
that fucking hard.
This is not like a guy who's never done
it before stepping in and doing brain
surgery.
No,
of course,
of course.
But,
you know,
listen,
I got the job on the apprentice.
I did everything like opposite.
Of course I had been dabbling here and
there.
Right.
So then I got the job and then I worked
with a coach and I still work with a
coach now.
But when I got a big episode on blue
blood,
she comes over the house.
It's a dog,
you know,
Donald's friend join?
Objection,
you know.
No,
she's not working with a lot of cooks.
She could comes over the house.
I go over the lines we talk about
when you do that.
Um,
do you,
do you like read with her?
Does she read along?
Yeah,
what I'll do is,
you know,
uh,
what I'll do is I started learning the
lines,
then we'll talk about it or what do you
think?
Hey,
I have my ideas are ready.
She'll give me some notes and that's a
good idea.
It's good to get even getting the Fini
had two different acting cultures.
He worked with this girl Susan for years
that helped you get a different
perspective.
Oh,
you know what,
I didn't think of that.
I didn't think that one.
Yeah,
you're right there.
So that kind of shit.
Now look,
ultimately you get on the set,
you're going to do what you're doing.
The director's gonna Hey Steve,
you know,
you shouldn't be so angry.
They're whatever,
you know,
he thinks and the guy that wrote it,
you know what I mean?
But I worked very hard at it and I
worked for years now.
Now don't forget I'm making a living for
16 years as an accurate and I left the
Riviera in 2000.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
Sixteen years.
So,
and I've done a lot of shit.
This is you saying that 2016 years ago
makes me go,
what?
Is that right?
Yeah,
I left there.
I started on the Sopranos in [inaudible]
99.
I went back and forth for a year.
You know,
I didn't quit.
The judge did six episodes.
I was still at the.
What is it like how it must've been
fucking strange.
I was still at the river.
Then I booked it for 10 years.
I know I booked the river until 2010.
Chris Rock said you're still dipping
your toe
when that shit.
I said,
why not me?
What the fuck?
How hard is it?
Hard?
Is it to fuck a book?
Three comics a week.
I could do it in three days.
Booked up six months.
That's hilarious.
You know the book I book guys that you
know,
that didn't work much,
you know.
Well I think your point is a really
important part of what you're saying is
like the getting a different perspective
or a guy like Kendall feeney.
You would,
you'd imagine he was so good.
You would imagine that he probably
looked at it from all sorts of different
things.
Yes,
he did.
And you saw a lot of different colors,
but he,
you know,
he would work 16 hours,
16 hour days on the Sopranos.
He's in,
he's there.
So I mean the guy gets up whatever time
you got up,
then he's got to go home and learn
tomorrow stuff.
So sometimes he told me he'd be sitting
in the chair.
He Fall Asleep for two hours.
He wakes up,
she's still just waiting for him to wake
up and they're going to work on the
stuff with tomorrow.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And then,
and nine months of that,
don't forget,
you know the Sopranos,
Joe,
they were,
when I got on the show was like eight
days.
I came on the second season,
so it was like eight days for an
episode.
They're nine and 10 at the list season.
It was,
we did,
we shot nine shows in nine months.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
You know,
it was like shooting a movie.
There's no commercials,
so it's a full hour,
but you know,
that's what it was,
man.
It was long.
It was like shooting a movie.
Wow.
I mean,
month and episode.
The first episode was 17,
18 working days.
The rain,
brock was said to me,
you're going to work more in this
separate so that I will the whole season
because she only worked one day in
episode,
you know,
she had the greatest job in show
business.
They shot that in one day.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
For her.
Was a great part two.
Yeah,
it was great.
You know,
but I,
I think the coaching wise,
and I think a lot of it is,
you know,
you focus and concentrate,
know your stuff,
know your lines.
I mean,
you're an actor,
you know,
know your shit.
Don't come in and be like a smart ass.
Yeah.
Maybe I paraphrase.
Know your stuff,
respect what's on the page.
You know that I'm a,
I'm a big believer in that.
The Sopranos,
you didn't Ad Lib the word thought and
I'm not joking you.
There was a,
there was a time that I had to say,
uh,
I got to go and the line was I have to
go.
And they kept correcting me and correct
me.
Correct,
because I just,
you know,
I gotta go home.
I have to go.
I don't know why,
why,
when I didn't question it.
I mean,
you know,
but that's a crazy amount of work where
you're talking about Kendall feeney.
That's really,
that's still fucking with my head.
Now listen,
Jim was one of my closest friends,
couldn't find a better guy.
He worked hardly stories.
Kids,
you know,
his kids,
uh,
his daughter wasn't born,
you know,
uh,
while he was on the sopranos,
but it was like no life.
You could completely gave up your life
and not the rest of us because there was
so many characters,
you know,
I didn't,
I had a couple of episodes where I
worked a real lot,
but you know,
other words,
this can't be good for your health.
And.
Well it was a,
you know,
a lot of guys.
I mean,
I've,
I've heard,
uh,
I think Jimmy Smith's,
I read years ago and ypd he said he
couldn't take it was 18,
18 hour days and yeah,
it was making a fortune.
He said I couldn't do it anymore.
Yeah,
no,
I've,
I've had friends that have been on
dramas before and there's the same
thing.
He would tell me that they just,
they just couldn't do it and they would
just,
would be when the season would wrap
their to go,
this has got to be my last season.
I a point with the money now,
you know,
the thing,
what I love about blue bloods is there's
a lot of characters,
so there's different stories.
So it's not like that.
It's,
it's,
it's quite nice.
It's a beautiful show and you know,
like you said,
the writing's good network show,
but you know,
with Jim,
but he worked with,
you know,
a lot of,
like a dirty secret.
Working with an acting coach isn't,
that's a dirty little secret.
People don't want it.
Some people don't want to admit.
I think if you're a bigger,
I think pachino works with somebody.
Why don't know why there would be a
dirty secret.
I would think that would be just
practice.
That'd be a good.
No,
but I think like,
uh,
like guys don't want to admit that I'm
asking for him right now.
Guys say if I could ask this are,
you know,
comedians have a thing about that with
writers working with writers like
comedian working with a writer.
It's like other comedians will shake
their head and look down on you really
don't.
I don't understand that you write all
your own stuff obviously because your
stuff is very personal,
but they were all guys that it's
impossible for them to keep writing new
material.
Well these guys that are very personal,
but they have someone to work with.
Kevin Hart has guys that work with them,
like he has ideas and he bounces them
off these ideas,
these,
he's got these guys,
these ideas off these guys and then they
work on them together.
Like you'll,
he'll brainstorm with guys on his act,
which is nothing wrong with it.
Chris rock used to do that.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that.
But then there's guys like say a Leno or
Rodney who I was a big rodney
dangerfield.
Sure.
Everybody just comics,
facts and stuff into him all over the
place.
You know,
Leno.
I mean he was doing the show.
He's busy in his monologue there,
right in this stuff,
but not as standup.
Like when Lento does it stand up.
His standup is pretty much all leno.
It's all him.
But Rodney for sure.
And if there was a lot of guys like Bob
Hope,
Bob Hope had five,
six,
seven,
eight.
He had a staff of writers.
I know one of them,
he would pay $50 a joke and then the
only tip 37,
$50 job.
Mothers,
the richest guys ever the fuck it was,
but he was,
he would ask for a,
you know,
I need whatever,
whatever the event was,
you know,
I need jokes about trump or
mother-in-law,
this,
you know,
I guess comics don't want to admit to
it,
but there are comics that by no,
you know,
there definitely are.
And there's nothing wrong with it.
Like,
well first of all,
Richard Pryor,
who was the greatest of all time,
Paul Mooney wrote farm forever.
Yeah.
And other guys wrote for him.
And like I said,
Chris Rock was also one of the greatest
of all time.
Chris had a bunch of writers and smart.
He knows how to make the best comedy and
it's not necessarily always just with
your own mind,
like sometimes it's so hard.
It's not easy for someone else to find
your voice,
so you have to find those guys and it's
not easy because she,
I could say,
hey man,
you know,
write me either.
Sometimes like when I have to hold
something,
like I hosted this a thing on TV.
I'm not saying I'm not making believe
I'm a stand up.
I'm not a standup comic,
nor would I even attempt,
but it's more like a monologue,
you know?
Even if I have to host a charity event,
I have a guy who likes me jokes,
but he's,
I get my voice shit that I would say,
you know what I mean?
And you know immediately and you know,
well sometimes it's not a bad idea to
have a writer just because you have a
couple other guys that you can talk
about your set with,
you know,
because if you're just looking at it
yourself,
like we were talking about having a
different perspective.
Maybe even they don't write the jokes,
but they talk about the jokes that
you've written and give their
perspective and alone will probably help
you improve them.
I agree.
And I think if you're doing a live show,
if you're hosting something,
whether it be an award show or whatever,
to have a couple of guys there,
a spur of the moment thing,
give you some,
a joke.
Here's a good line.
But,
but uh,
you know,
spur of the moment is very well,
especially a live show,
like a talk show or something like that.
Very important to have writers.
Do you like doing talk shows?
No.
You don't like it?
No,
I don't like to just like doing this.
This is what I like because there's no
format.
When you do a talk show,
it's all shut off field of view when
they're going to.
I'm going to say this,
you're going to say that and then a lot
of time want to do it.
A talk show host has the joke,
the joke on top of your job,
right?
He's already got the retort.
Exactly.
I just don't.
They just seems fake and forced while he
right back now.
Now you have to sing and dance.
I don't know.
You have to be a variety show like the
guy.
Uh,
you know,
that's,
that's the new thing.
I appreciate a guy like Jimmy Fallon,
who does it well.
I think he's great at it.
I really appreciate it.
I just don't want to do it.
I just don't.
I don't want to be a guest.
I don't want to watch.
I don't,
I don't want to sit there.
I've had friends that do them.
I go visit them while they do it.
Like I watched Conan and the other day I
had a buddy of mine who was singing the
song and cone and I went to watch and I
was like,
get the fuck out of here.
I think it's a dying format.
I think it's a format that's like a
dinosaur.
Well,
I think it is,
which is why you see this guy on cbs,
James,
whatever his name is,
he's singing karaoke in the car.
Who?
This Guy James,
according as his name.
James Corden.
They sing.
Karaoke is mixing it up.
He's doing different time.
Yeah,
and he's got two different office.
He had a deli at this one.
They're trying to do different stuff and
I think it's become more like that than
just to sit down old fashion,
you know,
because first of all,
and I know most actors,
whatever celebrities,
they don't have a whole lot to say.
Some people like Deniro.
If it ain't on the page,
just guy is stuck at hello.
You say hello to him.
He stopped for a fucking answer.
How is that possible?
Well,
because he's got to have it on the page
and then he's a wonderful actor and he
could forgive you all this,
but if he.
You think he's going to come in here and
talk to you like this?
I don't know.
Shit.
No,
no.
Hell No.
You never spoke to him.
My friend Joey,
Joey Diaz.
You Know Joe Joe?
He did a movie with him.
Yeah,
he enjoyed it.
He liked it.
It was just an honor.
You know what I mean?
You're working with arguably the
greatest actor of all time,
top five,
but I don't think he's ever seen him to
try to do a talk show.
It's never boring.
Look at some clips.
Well,
I think he's an interesting guy.
You know,
Deniro is a very unusual guy.
I think he's done a lot of crappy stuff
and I don't know.
I don't understand how much money do you
need that I know you want to work and
this is what you do for a living and I
get it,
but you know.
Yeah,
he's done some shitty movies for sure,
like really shitty movies,
but I think he's probably.
Well that was the recent one.
You did the temp.
I watched the ad and I just.
My whole soul starts shaking like I was
freezing to death.
Like you know,
I,
I don't know.
Boy,
he owns the restaurant and she's got to
a hotel in Vegas.
Nobo.
He's got a million restaurants.
She's got these old tales at Tribeca
film festival.
And at what point in time are you gonna?
What are you gonna do with that money
when you die?
He just enjoys doing shitty movies.
Well,
I don't think.
Enjoy shitty movies.
I think he enjoys doing movies.
I've got to say that there's a whole lot
of great roles for second city,
70 something years,
you know,
Pachino seems to navigate them better.
Yeah,
sorta.
He does some shitty fucking movies too,
but I think these guys,
you know,
they get up in age and the roles they
don't get offered the best roles and
then something comes along and it's not
that good,
but it's a lot of money and the guy,
fuck it.
Who Cares?
And they just do it.
And the other thing is a guy like
Pachino,
he has so much leeway because he can
kind of do whatever the fuck you want.
Same as as Deniro.
Like what was that one movie Deniro did
recently?
There was a fucking shit.
The name of that movie,
the movie with Bradley Cooper and
Jennifer Lawrence.
It was a big movie and Deniro played in
the hustle.
Yes.
He was good at that.
So he's still got it.
He's still got it.
He can still do it and seem like,
like a really dangerous fuck.
It's still possible to see those,
those,
those roles don't exist that often.
No,
it doesn't.
As you said that,
and as I think as we get older too,
you know,
physically,
you change,
you know,
just like,
just like a guy that was just wonderful
leading man in his thirties,
you know,
now he's a fucking bloated guy in his
fifties,
you know what I mean?
He can't be the same guy.
Yeah.
Bloated,
you know Val Kilmer,
right?
Like that kind of thing.
I worked with him.
How was he?
He was nice,
but out there,
he's out there.
I did a movie in Detroit with him.
He was way out that,
I don't know if you remember how he
likes to mushrooms.
Maybe he was on him that day because we
shot a movie out there and he was way
out there.
He was heavy then.
Yeah.
Now he did something in Africa with
somebody and they said he got whacked
out on mushrooms.
They're running around the campfire
fucking lines in the background.
Oh yeah.
I didn't see that,
but he was in Detroit.
He was nice enough.
But while he was in that movie,
that ghost in the darkness,
remember that?
No.
Michael Douglas in him,
the fucking lion hunting in Africa.
They were working on a railroad.
It was a fucking great movie.
And these two lions teamed up and
started killing the railroad workers.
You older?
Yeah.
It's like a,
I want to say like 90 ish.
That really early nineties is prime.
Oh yeah.
I wouldn't even bat,
man.
Yeah.
It's a great fucking movie.
The ghost in the darkness.
Him and Michael Douglas.
Michael Douglas.
Before he got cancer from eating pussy.
I mean those days.
I don't know,
for me posts.
He's the only guy in the world that I
know of.
Look,
everybody's got to be a first.
Yeah,
there it is.
That's the ghost in the darkness.
When he played the top gun.
Oh yeah,
Yup.
Same era.
Same time.
Yeah.
I think that guy got too much pussy,
lost his fucking mind.
Decided to try to eat themselves to
death and it just didn't work out.
And then he stayed alive and had a loose
coming back down and have him on this
love to.
I'm sure you'd love to what I imagined
he wouldn't.
Why wouldn't he have booze everywhere?
I would just say let's just do this.
Come on,
let's start.
You know what?
I think he did one of those,
he did one of those autograph shows,
autograph autograph shows.
They have like a,
like chiller theatre and the Hollywood
show,
whether you sell your autographs.
And I think he did one and he made like
$100.
A friend of mine told me,
made like 100 grand like he had the line
was,
you know,
so he just sat down and signed,
sit down and sign.
That's what know,
you've heard of these things.
I'm sure you've been offered that.
That never gets to me,
you know?
Oh,
I'll probably gets deflected.
But uh,
they,
they just had one that had one in
jersey,
you know,
where they had like Erik Estrada,
the other guy from chips,
the other guy,
you know,
all good times,
they have the cash.
Then you know,
this guys from my show have done it.
I don't want to do it.
I've never done it.
I personally feel it takes a little
piece of your soul when they walk by you
and go,
Oh,
do I want to buy Eddy munsters Pitsa oh,
bobby Bacala.
Alright,
I'll go with Eddie.
I think that takes you fucking sole job.
It's gotTa.
Take a chunk of it.
Come on.
Well,
I just also think that making people pay
for a signature is fucking crazy,
but I'm with you.
I do get admitted.
It's a little annoying when you run into
those guys to the airport and you got to
stack a shit.
They want you to sign 10 of them and
sell them.
That's not a fan of doing this.
Selling him or this.
They're wholesaling to another guy,
you know,
they just up the ladder like maybe it
maybe he says,
alright Rogan's going to be there.
I'll give you a $10 from time.
I'll just sign one and this one guy was
giving me a hard time.
I go,
dude,
I'm not working for you.
Do you understand?
I'm working with because he's like,
I took a train here.
I go,
I don't give a fuck.
I didn't ask you.
The only thing is for me,
sometimes it's easy to just sign the
phone station side of things and move
on.
Well,
you know,
I mean you could do it real quick,
but the whole idea behind it is weird.
He's like getting you to do something.
Then he's going to sell it.
Then they're going to put it on Ebay.
Well,
they all have the same standard stuff.
They have a microphone and want you to
sell.
Some of them have an MMA glove they want
or they want you to sign a MMA glove.
They want you to sign pictures,
pictures,
and I go,
wait,
you get that?
I don't even have the.
They get,
well,
they get them and then they know where
you're going to be a little glove,
what your signature.
That would be worth something.
I guess like five bucks maybe probably
cost you more in gas to get the picture.
I ran into a fucking guy once that had
fake shit.
A guy emailed me and he said,
Hey,
is this your signature?
And I was at a news radio script with
all the cast members.
I go,
not only that,
I'm not my script.
All those scripts,
all those signatures are fake.
All Andy Dicks,
because I knew Andy Signature.
He had a very distinct signature and
Phil Hartman had a very clean,
distinct signature.
I'm like,
these are all fake.
Yeah,
I still have one.
We did this poster from Cigar Aficionado
magazine that was floating around.
We all sign them,
you know,
we used to sign a lot of stuff at the
end of the read throughs for the
Sopranos.
They would have a stack of stuff for
charity and whatever to sign and it's
hanging in a restaurant in New York on
56th avenue.
It's not my signature.
Whoa is hanging up.
It's,
it's,
you know,
like seven of us,
but it's not my signature.
How crazy is that?
Someone's going to fake the hanging up
in a nice restaurant.
Bobby buck a lot with the fat stomach
because it's from the days when they
were the fat stone.
Oh,
they made you put like a prosthesis.
Then I got fat enough on mine.
Did you get fat enough?
Just so you have to wear that thing.
Oh,
what did they chase?
You know,
I,
you know,
when I first got the role I was seeing
all these jokes like you have cows on
with legs and you fat,
fuck,
and you think,
and I'm going,
I'm not that much fatter than getting
the Fini I'm starting to think that
maybe they kiss the wrong guy.
I'm not joking.
I'm saying it could be.
I mean,
did you jokes don't make sense.
And then they call,
oh you got to come in for a fat suit.
So I was ridiculous thing.
Then the second year they made it like a
really nice one that was like a costume
shop.
It had like tits and a costume shop in
like a Broadway costume thing.
And uh,
and then one year I was going back and I
was at a fitting for the fourth year,
you know,
like the next year.
And uh,
he looked at me and he went and you
don't have to wait at anymore.
I said,
all right.
So I'm assuming it was pretty
embarrassing at first I was prancing
around there.
They had an ass on me til like a big ass
fake ass and he was gone too big and I
was like going walking back and forth
like crazy.
It's fucking,
you will eat Steve Landesberg.
Remember the comment he said to me,
did they ask your permission to do that?
And I said,
no,
Steve,
he's,
I want him to fuck that.
I want.
Well I want to get the job.
You know,
that was a weird time when the sopranos
came out because all of the sudden there
was like a lot of fake mob guys.
A lot of fake connected,
fake Italian.
You know what I mean?
It's still around.
I call a Gig Guinea Act guilt,
but you know what I mean?
It's like that acting that way became in
fashion.
Take started it.
They used to hang around wherever we
weren't.
They were around,
they were extras.
They was still around,
but there was,
you know,
we did a appearance in the casino.
We do a lot of that stuff.
You know,
they were everywhere.
They were everywhere.
They were hoping to get on the show.
He come out and you did the shotgun.
I could do the show.
I remember Michael Imperioli one time.
We were up in Reno and there was one of
them and he was playing blackjack and
you know,
and uh,
he except come on,
put me on the show.
I could tell you though,
I had just went off on him.
I've been trying for 20 years and you
know,
blah,
blah blah.
Then he got he,
he hit Michael and Michael was right.
He got really pissed off.
This is just one of those fucking
Goombas,
you know,
and the guy I could door.
You do the worst.
Exactly.
This like this wannabes,
but there's something about Guinea
wannabes.
This allows,
is a handful out here.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's the thing here.
They congregate together when they try
to like up together.
What's the last thing?
Rogan.
How come you got Rogan?
What's the book?
I kind of tried to navigate away from
that.
Even in New York,
I kinda,
it's not my thing.
And Soprano's was so good that it almost
killed the mom genre.
You know?
I think so.
I think you're right about that because
you know what,
unless,
and I get a lot of scripts,
Joe,
in all of that crap,
you know,
they make these,
I call them back yard movies,
you know,
you're never going to see him,
whatever they're getting paid.
I'm not interested because it's that
same thing.
I'll fuck you up.
You know,
I am,
you know,
my uncle is like a [inaudible] sketch,
but it's true.
But they write this and I say how people
give them the money.
How do you get the money to make these
movies?
Well,
I think for awhile people were making
them just because it's Pr Sopranos was
so pocket,
but now,
unless you're going to beat Sopranos
Goodfellas,
you know,
what's the great mob movies?
Supra,
Sopranos,
Goodfellas Casino,
a raging bull head Marbella elements,
right?
Great movie.
Uh,
one of my mission there was to be a few
of them,
you know,
some great,
great,
great mob movies.
But right now it was after the Sopranos.
I mean,
you don't see the Godfather Godfather to
know that there was some,
but you're gonna have to beat that.
Then they tried,
they tried to do some mobby stuff,
ray Donovan's work,
and that's a good chill.
That's a good show.
When that's from an Irish perspective.
Yeah.
Well I think what happened with those
movies was,
or,
or uh,
that show rather is,
it was those,
you had a movie every week.
Exactly.
So like every subject was covered.
Betrayaled gambling.
It was funny.
It was funny,
funny,
funny elements.
It was very smart.
That was something,
you know,
I would go,
I would be around and people go,
I don't like that show you on.
I'm Italian.
Have you ever seen this show?
Have you ever seen the show?
No,
I haven't seen it.
It's like it's a,
it's just somebody I,
I don't,
I don't watch porn.
I hate porn.
Have you ever seen it?
No.
Well then how do you know you don't like
it?
Or did you see it or do you watch it?
You know what I mean?
But really they're holding signs up.
I will know porn.
Well,
that was a big thing,
right?
The Italian American boss society was
telling you're testing against it.
I bought this story.
I wrote a kids book,
Nikki Deuce,
okay.
Uh,
it took place in Brooklyn and we turned
it into a movie for Nickelodeon,
you know,
which we didn't just want to get in the
phoenix slash movies and I had Michael
Imperioli in it and so rico and uh,
uh,
and Nickelodeon made the movie,
but when I was,
when I wrote the book,
I was doing book signings and you know,
it's about a kid fish out of water who
goes back to Brooklyn and grew up in the
suburbs and he winds up with a kid,
entire neighborhood,
Bensonhurst,
Brooklyn,
and then it gets into some mischief.
I don't even call it trouble,
but so is guy kept writing letters and
shit and killing me on the Internet and
writing letters to the bookstores.
A head of me getting there,
you know,
like saying that he's a derogatory
against Italians and he's now he's
bringing kids into it and blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
So finally I get the guy's number and I
called the guy.
I swear to you,
I say to him,
listen,
I think his name is Zane.
I think his name is anthony.
I said,
listen,
Anthony,
blah,
blah.
This is the world I know,
like rappers rap about what they know.
This is what I know,
you know,
and uh,
he said to me,
I said,
you know,
what can I do?
Tell me what I can do.
Let's fix this.
I mean,
because,
you know,
blah,
blah.
He said,
well,
you can make a donation to my
organization.
It was the Italian American bullshit.
I said,
you got to be kidding me.
100 true story me down.
There's a whole bunch of,
when the movie came out,
we got some heat for the Nicky deuce
movie.
Really?
And it's not really about mob,
it's just want attention.
I mean,
exactly.
You know,
and they did that with this problem of
people would say all the time,
you know,
Joe,
uh,
yeah,
I don't want you to thing I'm an
Italian.
You guys talked bad about a time.
You know,
they didn't,
they,
they showed what really was.
I thought it was very authentic,
you know,
oh,
well,
this apprentice is authentic as it gets.
If you know anybody like that,
you know those people exist.
Absolutely.
And I take a 10.
They don't exist.
Is it fencing?
Exactly.
And I think it was a story that need to
be told.
This is what it is,
but it was such a fascinating show
because Gandolfini was a bad guy,
like his character.
You're rooted for a bad guy,
a murder for a murderer who cheated on
his wife,
stole rob,
shook people down,
but he was your guy.
He was,
I think the first.
I think I could be wrong.
The first like anti hero that people
were deformed.
I think you're right.
I,
I can't imagine that it was,
you know,
your,
your roof for the guy,
you know,
he was a real anti hero.
No murderer,
a con man.
I mean all the above.
They,
they didn't just do it to people in the
mob.
They did it to people,
you know,
like on the show.
There wasn't just within each other.
They went outside,
they were robbing people,
busting up,
uh,
you know,
businesses and doing all this stuff that
they do.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was,
it was a very smart show and if it,
if they put it back on now,
they would get higher ratings than some
of their shows now.
I bet.
I bet they would.
Well,
it was so good.
I think a lot of people forgot how good
it was and it also changed a lot.
If you go to the first episode,
the first episode was essentially like a
slapstick comedy.
You remember that?
I'm not in the rain.
Brought out with the rain.
Brocco a who was the woman that played
his wife,
ed.
Ed Falco had a fucking machine gun and
the doctor was trying to outside with a
machine gun.
It was way more slapsticky.
It was weird.
It was like a thing.
Well,
they shot the show aired in [inaudible]
99,
right.
I think they shot that in [inaudible]
98,
if I'm not mistaken.
Really,
if I'm not mistaken at 98,
I believe.
[inaudible] 97.
Even.
They'd go back and then it took six
months and then they started shooting
them.
You know how how David Chase did it?
He didn't do it like a regular show
where you shoot it and then in three
weeks it's on the air,
you know,
he put them all in the camp.
They were finished and locked and you
know,
you know what I mean,
like,
you know,
you finished your,
your whatever.
It took nine months and then he edited
them and Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah.
And then they aired,
you know,
it was done a completely different way.
You also,
they would,
uh,
you know,
if they didn't like what you did,
I mean he replaced you and you never
even knew it.
Really?
Yeah.
He replaced,
you know,
like,
uh,
I,
I had a scene with a guy and they called
back,
you know,
a month or so later and said,
you've got to shoot the scene together
with a different actor for whatever
reason,
whether you know the guy didn't do a
good job or a,
he looked too young or too old or just
didn't fit.
He had the,
he had the capacity to just shoot it
again if it,
if it,
it didn't work.
He rewrite the scene.
You shoot the scene again three months
later.
What's interesting about those kinds of
shows too,
is that they're so big and so popular
that you become that character.
Whoever that character is,
you become that guy.
You're that guy forever.
That's of course.
I mean that,
and that's part of the deal.
That's okay.
I had no Korea before that,
so it's not.
Yeah.
I'm not saying with you what I'm saying,
like there's some people that you've
worked since then you'll continue to
work,
but there's some people that were on
that show that we're really famous when
that show was on the air
and the vanished.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you're in the,
you know,
you got people all over the world
watching.
I mean,
I've been stopped with people literally
from all over the world that have
watched a show.
It was like a cult hit,
like nothing that ever hit before,
like big pussies,
big pussy for the rest of his fucking
ass.
Vinnie's also.
He embraces that too.
You know what I mean?
Embraces that for him and works and he's
okay.
He works.
He does his thing,
you know,
he's always going to work.
He's a very good actor.
He's got his music,
he's a musician and stuff,
but I hear,
you know,
especially the name,
big pussy.
That was a big thing.
People like to say that.
Yeah.
They do like to say that,
but also his,
you know,
the scene in the movie when they kill
him,
like the whole,
the whole way it plays out.
It was very intense.
It was like,
Whoa,
I can't believe they killed big pussy.
Well,
if that was the big thing,
that was the first time to have regular
cast member gets killed.
Yeah.
I mean they're not killing the,
you know,
uh,
the guy from friends.
Exactly.
David Schwimmer and getting killed,
you know.
Oh,
one know one Friday night,
oh my God,
they killed David.
Tremendous.
Five friends now,
you know.
So that was a big character that gets
killed and then big characters kept
getting killed,
which is why guys will worry.
I mean,
there was a real concern that you
weren't going to get killed off the
show.
The more material they gave you,
the more of shot you're getting killed.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
and,
and let's not kid ourselves.
It's not just,
you know,
you're out of work.
They just put you out of work.
And the biggest show that Glenn,
when Gandolfini killed Imperioli,
I was like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
Pinched his nose.
I'm like,
what?
But,
but you know what,
once you made it into the last season,
it was like a,
listen,
you done,
you're paid.
However the story ends.
It's probably better if I would have got
killed early on,
I would have felt really shitty.
I'll tell you.
And so all the stuff that happened
because you know.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And plus,
you know,
we didn't mention we started making
money towards the middle and the end,
you know,
not the guys at the beginning while
making money.
Well those shows are hard to make money
like HBO is.
They don't worry,
you know,
Hbo Pace and they pay now even better
than the shows off the end.
Nine years.
Wow.
Now,
you know,
we went into,
and then there was other money coming in
because he had opportunities to do other
shit,
you know?
Well that show was also groundbreaking
in that it was one of the first shows
like that and now hbo specializes in
those kinds of shows and emc.
And so this show time.
Yup,
Yup.
That all kind of know in the Sopranos.
First time they,
they're hiring a,
you know,
a fat bald guy,
wasn't a leading man they wanted,
you know,
you figure he's the good looking guy,
you know what I mean?
But he was intense and charismatic and
one of the girls,
the girls loved them and we used to
joke,
you know,
they say TV puts 10 pounds on the.
I say it takes 50 off.
Yeah.
Well he was just such an interesting
character.
He was so intense and like when he got
into that murderous rage,
like you fucking bought it,
hook,
line and sinker.
When you acted with him,
you didn't have to,
uh,
you know,
get enough to act scared.
Like if it was a scene,
I got to be scared.
You're going to yell at me,
you know,
it was fucking,
he gave you the whole thing.
You know,
we had that fight,
you know,
me and him had that fight in the first
episode that,
you know what I mean?
You know,
we shot that for a day and a half.
Well,
that was tough.
He was choking me.
He said,
listen,
you know,
let's try to take this as far as we can
and we and turn it.
I was pulling his hair.
He was fucking choking me that I was
getting cut from the.
I was wearing a necklace,
you know,
I was getting cut from that.
I mean we've all banged up,
banged up for real and that's why I look
real.
It was like two fat out of shape guys.
Find the fuck out.
Don't you know guys,
it's not Steven Seagal.
Well,
you know what I mean,
you're,
you know what the hell.
This was like a fight.
So when you do something like that,
like how hard you hit each other,
you know,
as hard as you could without really
hurting.
And he had said that.
Let's go as far as we could and we were,
you know,
pull my head,
poke my head fucking of and choking me.
I had to go further,
you know,
like I said,
we were good friends,
you know,
if you do it with a stranger you could
get a little funky,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
well,
you know,
I had a fight scene it if he wants to
accidentally punched the guy in the
face,
um,
I meant to miss his face but he threw a
drink in my face and I was supposed to
punch him but I was supposed to like
punch him.
I hit him right in the jaw and he got to
go down.
But he was like,
but I didn't,
I didn't hit him hard,
but I hit him,
you know,
and like you see the look in his face
like you weren't supposed to hit me.
Like keep,
just keep going.
Yeah.
You know,
I had apologized and it was,
was he okay?
Yeah,
he was okay.
But you could see,
as you know,
when someone,
especially if you're not used to getting
hit on the jaw and you see that,
that dunk,
this shock and the sparks,
but fight scenes like that,
like you're fighting with Gandel Fini or
you know,
some movies that you watch people punch
each other and kick each other.
Like that guy just hit that guy like
that sometimes.
You know.
And look,
I think it's,
I know it was listened to guys on the
show.
He smacked me,
really smacked me.
She's,
you know,
they want that,
hit me,
you know,
I've seen that on a lot of stuff that
I've done.
And then some guys don't want no part of
it.
No Way.
No how but good smack me,
you know,
get the makeup girl and covered smack me
again.
You want that real reaction?
Yeah.
Eating on it.
I'm a big believer in eating,
you know,
I know you get sick of eating,
but that's the elite,
that fucking,
you know,
to show the movie and just keep bringing
stakes out.
Bring it out.
I'll just keep being not,
not because I have a glove because they
think it looks real.
The by,
you know,
if you noticed I'm a little cookie so I
noticed shit like that.
It looked.
They didn't really know.
Yeah.
Well that's the worst is when you see
someone who's eating a half eaten steak
and the next quarter eaten steak because
you know what the record is eating.
Would you put steak back?
You know,
what's the worst thing?
I don't smoke and I've never smoked
cigarettes.
You know?
Uh,
you see people smoking on TV and they
can't smoke.
Well they don't know what they're doing.
I know.
Exactly.
I wouldn't know.
I don't know how.
I mean,
what,
what is the deal?
We don't know.
You don't smoke cigarettes?
No.
But what would be the difference?
Is
a thing.
And do you smoke?
I think it's a casual thing.
You know,
it's like you,
you like how comfortable are you with
it?
I know,
but you see people that aren't,
you know,
like I've been asked.
I said I'll smoke a cigar,
which I don't even do that.
But I see cigar seems like so unusual
that anybody could do it.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's a cigarette.
You see people,
you got the sketch,
not a smoker.
No cigarette smokers do get crazy about
that.
Well,
there's certain things like here's the
one that drives everybody the most nuts.
That's a musician.
When you see someone fake playing a
guitar,
like someone's really jamming out and he
know they're not really hitting any of
the notes.
Like what is he don't even show his
fingers.
You fuck.
Stop it.
Or guys trying to cook or something.
You know,
this thing's gotta.
You gotta do your homework.
I would imagine to guitar one would
probably be like the worst because
there's so many complicated movements
and if you're like a person who actually
knows how to play and you watch it,
you would know that it's fake.
Fighting is that way too though.
Like you watched fight scenes in movies
when you,
you know,
like a boxing scene,
you know like Mark Walberg,
I think he's a very good actor.
But that movie the fighter where he
played micky ward,
like I'm watching him.
I'm like,
this is,
this is a guy that's not getting hit
like he's boxing,
like no one's hitting them back.
And when you think about like the rocky
movies,
terrible with the fight.
Scenes are terrible.
They're terrible.
They're the worst.
They're atrocious.
This one movie,
one guy,
but they're great movies as far as like,
look,
when I was a little kid I saw rocky and
I drank a fucking raw egg and I ran
around the block.
I never run in my life.
I mean,
unless I was playing baseball or
something,
I never ran.
But that movie made me go running.
I wanted to go running today,
so it wasn't,
it wasn't that they were bad movies,
but when you watch the boxing scene,
he's like,
get the fuck out.
Well,
the raging bull.
That was good.
That was.
That was Korea choreographed down to
this.
It was.
Well,
he recreated essentially what happened
with sugar ray Robinson and Jake Lamata,
but Deniro was a meticulous motherfucker
in those days.
You mean what it look kind of shape he
got in for that movie?
Looked like Lamanda.
I mean,
he looked like those days are over
meticulous rover now.
He's doing spring break.
No shirt on.
Oh,
you don't do the best boxing movie
though?
Daniel Day Lewis.
He did that movie.
The boxer.
He apparently lived like a boxer for a
whole year for that move.
Although he does that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
And you watch him box though,
like he's boxing like a boxer.
He's not boxing.
It's called the box.
Yeah,
it's called the boxer.
He plays an IRA guy that gets released
from prison and goes back to boxing.
Oh really?
That's good.
Very good.
He uh,
uh,
my uh,
buddy of mine was in the Lincoln movie
and he stayed at Lincoln,
Lincoln Fall.
Any character?
And he was wiggling.
I swear somebody said that he cut his.
He
sliced his thumb.
Yeah.
And somebody else let there be blood he
got.
He got annoyed that I'm sure he does.
He stays in character the whole time.
I guess he had a box for,
you know,
to cut that.
What he is above and beyond.
That's the guy that loses him.
Him Christian Bale.
They lose themselves in the characters.
A lot of people play it,
myself included,
you know,
I'm not going to play an English
professor,
you know what I mean?
Joe,
I play a blue collar guy,
you know,
whatever that is.
But some guys,
and those are two of them,
they just completely disappeared.
Gary Oldman and the Gary Oldman,
especially in the day like Kevin Spacey.
You still also true true romance with
Gary Oldman played the,
uh,
the white guy with the dreadlocks scar
on his face completely.
But those are the four that I really,
you know,
you know what I mean?
The four guys that you say,
it's a craft,
you know,
I mean,
it's that level.
It's a whole different level.
It's a different level.
And then you see a successful actors
play literally the same person over and
old canneries,
which you're saying,
yeah,
but he's good at it.
I'll tell you,
I said probably the same thing.
Yeah.
You know,
that and that.
Yeah.
And that's okay.
She's successful in whatever.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of actors when you go to
see the movie,
even though they're really good,
you want to see them play that
character,
you know,
like Christopher walken.
I'm looking for him.
I worked for them guys.
I want him to be that guy.
Why don't you be that guy?
But it's gotten.
Sometimes it's almost a character.
It isn't,
you know,
I did.
Uh,
I,
I've worked with him twice.
He's a good guy.
He's Latino.
Every movie has to have a rent.
There's gotta be some way.
Every movie.
He's got some crazy rant where he's got
to go on this rant.
I mean it's,
there was an old letterman clip that I
saw,
I just saw like yesterday day before
Kevin Spacey's doing Pachino to Pachino.
Really look for that.
It's really funny.
He does.
The thing is,
it's really funny.
Kevin Spacey is a bad motherfucker on
that.
Netflix,
that Netflix show.
No,
I don't think he's very good.
He's already fan.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He lets him.
It's interesting that Netflix is doing
stuff like that.
They're putting,
they're putting out their own original,
different,
different business model.
They're in a whole different deal,
you know what I mean?
That's a word.
I don't know how many people watch it on
watch,
but uh,
that's a huge.
Whoa,
what the fuck is it called again?
Fucks the Kevin Spacey's.
Thank you.
How can I not remember that?
He doesn't shave.
Talks low sometimes he ever jump in,
jump in if she wants to go.
He goes,
uh,
but yeah,
I just liked that they can do that now
they can produce their own content,
you know,
they can do anything.
Listen,
uh,
it's,
it's toy.
It's calling.
Have you seen that a bill burr show?
Efforts for family?
Yeah.
Did bill ever work for,
you know,
but I,
I,
you know,
I hosted a thing at the garden last
year,
had gotten into dreams a 5,500
people to kid's charity.
It's a good one.
And it was bill burr John Oliver,
Lewis Black Dane Cook and billy God
though.
And uh,
I met bill.
He's a funny guy.
His Greg Guy,
he's funny and he's a guy.
He's a real good guy.
He's a good guy.
I asked him,
what you see is what you get.
He's a really funny guy.
I mean,
uh,
and you know what?
I seen them on another charity,
the comedy central,
that thing,
and that's the first time I had seen
him,
but he's been around,
right?
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's a,
he was funny.
Makes me laugh a lot.
There's not that many comics that make
me laugh.
Laugh.
He's one of the best ever.
He's a Boston guy.
Yeah.
He,
there's not too many guys,
by the way.
He breaks a hell of a pie.
A Pie.
Baker.
It makes Pumpkin Pie.
It's fucking delicious.
Really good.
He gets into it.
He makes his own.
Start selling them,
selling them.
I'm already getting in trouble because
I'm late.
All right,
brother.
I ran it.
It was great seeing please anytime.
Whenever you're in town or you hear
often.
Uh,
no.
I haven't been because I've been
working.
I've been doing the blue bloods was the
last time you were here?
It's been about,
I'd say close to a year.
Anytime.
It's a pleasure.
If I'm in New York,
maybe I need to go to New York and just
set up shop there in New York.
A bunch of podcasts down there.
That would be good.
It would be a bunch of guys.
So how do people get your sauce?
One more time?
Cool.
Steve's NYC DOT com.
You could get it.
Also.
Albertsons,
fairway,
wholefoods,
fonds millions.
Go to our website,
uncle Steve's [inaudible] dot com.
You and it really.
It really is.
Good sauce and I know that.
That's why I sent it because I knew
because if you hated it and that would
be fine.
I would,
you know,
if you didn't like it,
you could tell me you don't like it and
we to talk about it.
It's not one person that told me it's
bad.
Beautiful.
All right ladies and talking to you man.
Please.